[Music]
just don't accept the way things are
done as the way that it has to be done
so just because they stop selling books
it doesn't mean that they can't sell
your book you don't pitch them as help
they sell my book
you don't pitch them we're not even
selling a book
the book becomes an
excuse to bring people into the store
who then will buy the products i'm gonna
have to
push myself out there and
be seen
in the house really she's part of
umaker's joined us for a year and as
part of that we do ig live together as
well so
shirlene welcome aboard oh thank you so
much it's my pleasure to meet everybody
to meet you i'm honored and to meet
everyone i am normally at work so i'm so
happy to get this opportunity to speak
with you i love it so
what do you got how can i help
yes well i am an author like at email
prior and probably your associates have
said to you and i've been practicing
natural and listicle for over 23 years
and everybody calls me guru i'm the
assistant vitamin manager at sprouts
everybody's like you should be on tv you
should be on youtube you i mean it's
it's just crazy like i'm telling them
like i'm almost like pastor joel's you
know kind of behind the scenes person
until
maybe god just pushed me in front but
for now
i was just telling them that i would
think
um i wanted god put it on my heart to
reach over millions of people well
millions of people to help them with
their health
naturally
and that's why i wrote the first book on
basically a pocket guide of eating for
your health
and then i'm working i'm a third of the
way off my second book
of mental health and wellness so the
first one was say yes to take care of
your
to to say yes to pure good food and then
the second one is say yes to taking care
of your mental health and wellness i'm
all about
wellness it was just a gift from god
23 years plus and i have to help the
people so i'm like
like oprah did with dr phil and
everybody else and dr oz and ianna to
get on their platform
i lo always been following evan for
years let me just reach out and join
this thing and support whatever he's
doing and he loves to help people so
you know i just reached out and just
said just leap of faith and we could you
know see if we could partner together
whatever he wants i was like whatever he
wants but i'm just uh
here to help the people
and you're also saying yes a lot
yes might say yes
yes i say i had to do that positive
affirmation you know i watch you a lot
and have been watching everybody from
you talk about everybody everybody in
the business from oprah to everybody
that you follow i've been following and
you know ian avanzan
um everybody you did everybody lisa
nichols
everybody that's been inspirational
those are the people i've been following
for many many years even before i found
you so
it's just my path of being
just that way just to help people
and i'm like this gift god of natural
health the stats are so bad in the
country one-third obese two-thirds over
their weight and i see people all day
long from a rush to stage four kansas so
it's just crazy so where are you stuck
or what do you need help with
meaning to get the word out there in
terms of the book so
people could use it to better their
health naturally i only use natural
remedies to take care of my health over
25 years so that
that part that's my gift of just natural
health not following that way because
i'm the assistant vitamin manager at
sprouts and i see people coming there 50
30 prescription
ailments all over the body going on and
in the community that i do live is a
quote-unquote affluent cell temple
area and i see and i tell them all the
time regardless of the money it's just
health is wealth regardless so they're
like i'm i'm you're here's my guru i'm
gonna always come in here for you and
they're just so honored to meet me and
to like i'm the local little person that
they always say she's the go-to and they
send people to me so i'm like
you know and i was just led to just join
the
thing although i did not know the
timeline of when you did your thing i
work at sprouts full-time as the
assistant vitamin manager i did not know
the timeline but it led on my heart to
just join
your movement and i said let me just do
it even if i just contribute to 500
because i never get a chance i'm at work
and i just said let me just do it and
then i said you know i would love to
partner with
you anyone anyone who
loves to help people and to
help other people
do you have for us to use our platform
to help people well first off listen all
the trainings are saved as well so you
can always even if you're not watching
live you can go back and watch them
watch all the reasons yeah i've been
trying to catch up
yeah what's the promotion strategy right
now for the book
i have that's that's the pro that's the
point it's just been locally on it's
been on amazon it's self-published on
amazon it's just been there and locally
i was selling the book locally and i've
sold hundreds i've i really have locally
just by myself i work full-time in
school full-time and i'm a natural
holistic health um coach outside of this
and consultant outside of this so i'm
trying each so i sell
there when i meet one-on-one with
clients outside of this because i tell
you these people have no idea in terms
of eating for their health i didn't
realize how bad it was until i started
consulting with people one-on-one so do
you want that's my strategy online
uh up
anywhere and about anywhere and my
one-on-one so far a full good amount
several hundreds
locally no promotion yet do you wanna in
terms of social media are you trying to
sell the coaching consulting service as
well
no i'm just
well what do you you're the expert in
this with social media i have no idea
what you suggest well i don't know okay
so social media becomes that becomes
your
marketing path but it's more like what's
on your heart what do you want to do do
you want to do you want to just be the
writer do you want to be the writer plus
the coach do you want to be speaking
like you want to be write a plus coach
i take that writer plus coach because
i've been coaching before i start
charging and i basically charge like 89
i tell you right there 89 an hour and
they're glad i'm just so happy and
elated after the one-on-one meeting so i
know i was like goodness i didn't
realize the market for they're like we
need more of you i was like i wish i
could multiply i've been hearing that
for years do you have a look yeah of
people who bought your first book
um some some is in my phone some okay
some of them the best content that you
can put on social
and you know instagram and youtube
uh will be the one that you actually
enjoy the most which will be helping
people
so
yeah
the easiest way no i was saying that i
don't want i it was never my dream to be
on youtube and have a youtube channel
personally i thought i would go the
route of partnering with other people
who have a platform and do it that way
it was just never
my dream
of being on there myself literally doing
that one-on-one i know i know everybody
say i should be but it's not my dream of
making videos like i see you do i rest
on my heart for years to just partner
with people who have a platform and do
it that way like yeah that that's the
way i i laid on my heart and to be
honest with you i have to say so
never the one to like go and make videos
and vlogs and
and all that
well you also do vlogs there's a
specific style of video and and you
don't have to do this either um
the more that you have your own
platform the less you're at the mercy of
other people as well so that's something
you can't sure but that you can't um
go and part with other people as well i
love that uh one of the reasons why
kevin hart started to blow up and could
command so much money from the movie
studios was because he built his
platform and he can say hey if i'm in
this movie i'm bringing people along the
watch as well
not just being the talent center
um
it's smart but it doesn't mean it means
lots of smart things you could do it
doesn't have to be the thing that you do
the trick would be like how do you make
it actually fun right most of the time
like making a video might be boring
might be like you just sit in front of a
camera you may not like doing that but
if you made coaching videos then that
could be
a fun path to go down where you're
actually helping people so i thought
like if you have a list of some of the
people who bought your books
the first book
yeah but yeah i do but i don't know if
they're
because it's a one-on-one about their
health their privacy
in terms of that if they would want to
do that just it's just a thought
in terms of their private information
and private stuff that we talk about is
just
private in their coaching of their
health one-on-one so i
yeah i don't
see how yeah that part i don't really
know how i would make a video with them
with that part so some people won't
and some people yeah some people would
have no problem with it
like if oh if people will go on jerry
springer and talk about the things oh
god they talk about it
no you're too funny with that no jesus i
caught in her number i don't yes
yes i don't watch those things but i've
glimpsed everybody on in the world i've
seen the riot and the
yeah that's uh a lot i'm a christian
driven person but i i don't watch news
but i've seen your springer once or
twice and it's a mess
we'll go on and share their story there
uh some people will come on and share
their story with you and and
if you saw the clientele that i have you
would probably think that they mostly
wouldn't
based on how their demeanor and how they
are they wouldn't
be that kind of type of crowd like jerry
springer they're very yeah sure yeah i
mean and just the point is there are
some people who will share and there are
some people who will share you don't
need everybody you just need a few
people who will come on and share
and the way to do it especially if you
like the idea of being a coach
then i do
if it's if it's like making a video like
what's this we're doing this is coaching
it's just flipped
so oh my god
don't put me on a spot i know i know i'm
listening to you that's why i'm not
saying anything i'm listening so then it
would just be flipped where you're
you're then helping people with their
whether it's the mindset stuff or the or
the nutrition stuff either one
interesting not trouble but the second
book is more about mindset right
yes the second book is mental health and
wellness because i yeah every one of
them when you do read it you'll see i
don't i want a way i don't know to get
you a copy just yeah just to have a gist
of what i do because everybody i've been
so thankful about i've just heard a
hundred percent i'm not even 99 100
positive review about this book they're
like this book needs to get out there i
was like i'm trying they're like yes you
need to get out there talk to people who
have a platform i said i've already
thought that's one of my
main thing that has been resting on my
heart to do so i'm trying so i said you
know what
better than
you
who have always loved to help people and
just have a good uh you know just a good
aura about you
and i just that's why i signed that even
though i've never been on any of the
training i was like okay i'm never gonna
ask my father's money but i'm just i've
joined all of his things and just like
what he's doing in the world and i'm
sure
everybody's like
the thing that everybody keep coming
back without the coaching or they bought
the book
you just got a gift
you just got that gift of health
health is wealth and you've got that
naturally we need more people doing it
that the stats are too bad
here in america you just if you anybody
you partner you will be all right
because we need more of that especially
it's a pocket guide
my favorite book is a hundred is 91 page
and that's where i got the idea to make
it short under 100 page 100 pages so it
is
under 100 pages and
yeah i have gazillion books some of them
probably similar to yours because i
follow any thought leader always years
on end it's just been my path
and and i'm like this lay on my heart to
write this book and i finally
god made my former store manager was the
author of 15 books who know how god
lined up things and got this first one
published and
now we're we're friends for life and
then he knows i'm writing my second one
he has 15 books on
amazon
so just
just how god has weaved it and then here
i am with you
i mean i just like i said he just like
go ahead and join evan's thing i just
listen i just listen and i know i don't
even i didn't know your schedule know
how i was gonna do anything i just find
what what about sprout
yeah sprouts they use i this was one of
gonna be my big thing sprouts used to
sell books straws used to sell books so
i said okay i was gonna get my book into
olive sprouts couple months before uh my
book was published
sprouts stopped selling books
at all they got rid of books said that
was gonna be my major idea just to speak
with higher up ask my store manager
because we're very close and he he just
love he's just like yes he's just a big
supporter too of
what i'm doing my natural health mission
to help people and he's like yeah so he
would have helped me but it's
unfortunately they
they totally took
all
books out of all sprout stores the memo
came down that they're going to get rid
of all the books so
that was just what it is i said on
another opportunity will open do you
work at a specific store or you work for
the whole company
oh yeah specific store in south tampa
here i work near home okay i'm in south
tampa as the assistant vitamin manager
so here's the thing with any of these
things like you can't accept
just don't accept the way things are
done as the way that it has to be done
so just because they stopped selling
books it doesn't mean that they can't
sell your book um
one of the things that i did uh when i
was getting started as a speaker is i
went to
uh i'm in canada so the canadian version
of barnes nobles
like the biggest bookstore in the
country biggest bookstore chain
and
i said i want to come in and speak at
your
at your location
and they said but you don't have a book
it's like no i i don't want to i don't
have a book to sell but i'll help sell
your books
i'll bring people into the store
and so
they thought it was a little crazy but
whatever they gave it a shot and
yeah i spoke there
uh
either every week or every two weeks for
like a year and we had the second
largest number of people come out to the
bookstore
um
apart from sting sting was number one
and the musician sting was number one
and we were number two
and oh wow because people kept coming
back and so
sure they don't sell books anymore cool
one if you're already at a specific
store
you have some you have relationships and
you have some leeway and you could
probably make it work as a launch just
at that one store but here's
yeah but i've got to tell you something
here
real quick so you have an inside it's a
total
different dynamic real quick in one
sentence uh the management has changed
and it's a total like turnover of
employees and not happy and it's crazy
it's different i'm on the verge of
trying to even decide
how long i'm going to stay and all of
that so it's a little bit
different from when the former manager
was there so different totally so yeah i
mean all of that creates opportunity
it's like take take the lemon and you
make lemonade and then you sell it yeah
you know like all of it so
yeah i believe you're not
the goal you don't pitch them as help me
sell my book you don't pitch them we're
not even selling a book
the book becomes an
excuse to bring people into the store
who then will buy the products
i told them that that's what i was using
until she stopped um the new management
manager
um
her voice dropped and she said yes
they're
not
put it this way they're not for many
people they're not people persons like
yourself to help and all of that it's
more of
sabotage and jealousy it's been going on
throughout the store it's crazy just
different managers can bring different
things
uh yeah i it's crazy because i'm in a
management class i have a year of doing
a management degree just for my bucket
list not any particular reason i found
my passion 23 year plus a girl but i'm
just saying yeah management 101 of
taking care of your people that's not
what the been feeling in the store
lately so not for if it was the other
manager sure i would have done that sure
it's just a different pitch right it
it creates opportunity it's not a
problem it's an opportunity so the pitch
is the support team
it doesn't even matter about you the
pitch is let's grow the business
and if yeah that's what i told her and
it was
it was and she still she want me to
still bring all my custom i had a store
locally for four years and i had one
online and they'd all
converted to sprouts and i she knows she
knows i'm our money maker making the
money but guess what that at the same
time my direct management her their they
want to shut no thriving
they're not people persons they don't
want to see you succeed so it's not even
a thing they're trying to you get
use you take your your your people and
the money but not to
promote anything if i put it bluntly
they want to just do that and shut it
down like evan i'm trying on your book
but i still want to use you and your
people and all of that not like a good
partnership to say okay
like i am here like
whatever partnership you want with me
i'm fine enough with fear enough with
whatever i'm a giver or whatever like
that's what i mean no open like that i
believe in two-way street no it's not
that kind of dialogue it's wanna i'll
use evan and his people but no ever nope
for your book a note for this but i'm
just sorry
yeah awesome then then you find another
store
yeah like the model works
if you're saying hey i don't want to do
content i don't want to do coaching i
don't want to make videos
cool that's one way to win partnerships
on your heart you know what you said
it is cool so what it is so this is part
of partnerships right some people will
take advantage of you some people won't
listen to you that's a lot of rejection
cool you just got to navigate and deal
with it
the model works i will right like the
model works i will so if it's just this
maybe it's a different sprout location
maybe it's a different health like how
many health food locations are there
or even wellness locations yoga studios
dance studios like anything that deals
with health or wellness for the two
books
that
they could have somebody come in like
you
giving a speech like they may be
something they've never done before
true but it brings value to their
to their community to their customers
true so i'm an introvert like you i do
everything i did but you're doing it so
i'm following you i am yeah i have her
speaking it was at the ymca
and
i um they didn't have they didn't bring
in speakers it wasn't a thing that they
did
but i said hey i'd love to help your
entrepreneur group and share my story is
it okay and i came in and presented
there and then i i started i came back
to the ymca and then i went to a local
bank
um and then evolved into the bookstore
and although all along the way it's like
stuff they had never they've never seen
this before they've never done this
before
but okay it's the willingness like you
make a list of 200 stores
and
20 of them will say yes
and the other 100 and you know 80
maybe they're bad people maybe they're
just stressed out maybe they just aren't
closed-minded maybe they don't support
management cool i mean
we love you i mean let me show you that
it works
and then as it works
then you can like if you can make it
work with one sprouts location forget
about the one that you're in cool
make it work bring people into the store
they start buying other products then
now now you're going on a sprouts tour
you're hitting up america going to every
spouse location
right and if it's not sprouts and it's a
it's a yoga franchise or it's just yeah
yeah i was thinking that i was waiting
for you to say that because i don't yeah
i would yeah would probably try you know
other people don't place them okay
sprouts it doesn't have to be sprouts
yeah but there's lots of companies that
are like sprouts so sell health products
or services right dan studios et cetera
um where they would find it cool to have
somebody come in
they're looking for creative ways to
market their business they're dealing
with people not showing up they're
dealing with inflation like they're
looking at anything um they're looking
to get their name out right like um can
we bring some media to the event can you
can you
like once anybody says yes then you kick
up
a firestorm you start
emailing all the local media and say hey
we're doing we're doing this act of
kindness in our community here i'm an
author i wrote this book i'm
volunteering to go speak at this yoga
studio to spread awareness around mental
health and physical activity and out of
the 40 reporters you email four will
pick it up and say oh that's actually
pretty cool
it's momentum so it's like it's what
kevin hart did right when he did his
tour back to kevin hart like he was
touring as a community before anybody
knew who he was or cared about him and
any everywhere he went he just made it
he got their email addresses and built
his list and then the next time he came
back there were double the people there
and the next time he came back there was
like four extra number of people there
and if you want to do partnerships as
your main strategy that becomes a path
you know like hey i'll come in i'll
present i'll do q a i've got to book
this out too people want to buy it but
the main focus at the beginning is not
sell the book the main point is to help
customers who are helping people yeah
yeah completely helping people with
their health is is my main
thing totally i totally agree my main
thing is is
yeah forget about that once i help
people with their health
they're always inclined to buy i realize
the book or whatever else that comes
it's just
get that get that to help people but i
know i didn't want to be in front but i
based on all your strategy i'm gonna
have to push myself out there and
be seen even though i would rather be
like you at first and just kind of not
be seen but
give a great talk at the yoga studio
then maybe they sell your book
you know like you're building
relationships
yeah building relationships i gotta be
seen so i gotta put it in my head i
gotta do it i just gotta
go out there and totally put myself out
there to these places even though i
didn't wanted to be behind the scenes
somehow
but i got i hear you and i respect you
so i will be trying to get brave burr
trying to get braver
or trying to get brave
to do it yeah
i'm going to try you make a if
partnership is the way you want to go
then you make a list of 200 people
who have places that you can go and
speak at that are related to health and
wellness somehow
that you can you can help their audience
their customers and totally help and
then the goal becomes
you have to refine the the model in the
system but as you start doing these
events whatever four people show up 15
people show up 20 people show up like
it's building the model yeah but then
you can yes to
a national franchise
and then go on a
north america tour
spreading health and wellness to their
audience
oh my god
you think big and i and i like it but
lord i i have to try to
to process it i just yeah give me a
while to process it i was thinking
behind the scenes
and just do my little partnerships don't
stress but i know i am trying to process
it sometimes sometimes the big thing
becomes too big and then it's scary and
then we don't do anything so
don't stress it doesn't have to that
doesn't have to be the thing but
yeah you can work towards it and we take
one baby step at a time because you know
that yes totally i believe in that baby
10 years ago wouldn't have thought that
you'd be writing books and now here you
are with the second one coming out
i know i know totally i'm like
yeah that part i was like look at that
totally yeah i agree i chose everybody
make a list of 200 stores
local businesses all right that do
health and wellness in your area that
you can go in
and do some kind of presentation to
that will help their audience
and see
all right so i will take i will take
that as my thing for you but please
consider me in terms of partnership with
me i've been always wanting to do one
with you so if
just let me know how you'd want to
proceed and go about that i mean you
never know
it's not
right like as you start doing these
things
the model becomes a lot more clear so
then you can go to people
and
be able to have something tangible to be
able to give them
as a model
okay
all right i will take that i appreciate
you and appreciate your time for
everybody watching what's the name of
the book again
tell us both of them
say yes to pure good food
is the first one and the second one of
course and the one is coming out yes
that's on amazon yes and the second one
is going to be say yes to taking care of
your mental health and wellness i'm a
third of the way and when is that so
i my goal is december okay listen
i'm trying to do this
uh
school and work wise how do you spell
how do you say your last name
everybody called me that from high
school so i'm gonna take it but it's
actually we no but it's true
everybody say why w e i s e go check her
out shirleen thank you for the love
thank you for the smile thank you for
your first listener we made it happen
yes i know i would jesus thank you so
much thanks everybody and thank you so
much evan i really appreciate it i
totally i'm honored to meet you thank
you soon thank you
thank you
bye all right everyone so chrissy
matthew in the house uh she's she's an
awesome member of movement maker she's
been with us now for over a year and as
part of that we're doing in uh
an interview together so she's gonna
interview me she's had some questions on
her mind and
ah
so yeah i've just been there's certain
things that i've meant to ask you from
about your website and you know your
story's on your website and and since
the beginning so like at the top
you say it's not your fault right and so
my first question is like you throughout
school were you know struggled you went
through three different schools had
challenges
and you said is one of the things that
it's not your fault you know society
you've been limited people tell you what
to do what to be be realistic
at what point do you think that
start
telling young people to
that you know don't dream big anymore
it's not uh you know
you know be realistic type thing a
couple of the things that you had said
on there and why do you think that is
yeah what what a start um
i know you do a lot of work with kids so
this is a great this is a great kind of
theme into it um
honestly i think it's even before they
say anything i think if you ask the
parent
who's got a six-year-old or a
seven-year-old or an eight-year-old and
and the kid wants to go and be
a whatever i think when they're really
young the parents are we're usually
pretty encouraging
like yeah you can go do anything you
want and it's and it they have to take
it more seriously once they're looking
at university and college like
graduating high school and like what
courses are going to pick but i think
even more than the words people say is
the actions that they're doing and so if
you have a six-year-old at home when
you're you're teaching her to go and and
do whatever you want and be you could be
xyz but then you're not living it
yourself
i think the actions speak a lot louder
than the words
and so uh
a lot of parents i think are not off
just most people most people are not
living the life that they want most
people are not chasing down they've got
goals they've got aspirations they've
got dreams and they're not taking the
steps to do it and so you can say
something to your kid but if you're not
off demonstrating and improving it
i think your kids are much more likely
to see how you act as opposed to listen
to what you're saying
uh and so that then the challenge
becomes okay what would
you know if you won't do it for yourself
for the parents out there if you won't
do it for yourself
your kids because they're so true so
true because you know
obviously even with adults who lead by
action you know we we are the example of
what young people
um look up to and then when they see
especially their parents what they do
do you incorporate your son in a lot of
what you do in your business
only what he wants you know i think like
the the best part about my parents is
they always gave us the freedom to do
whatever
we wanted to go chase down there there
was expectations that we would do
something but not expectations to do
something specific
right it's like we had to go we had to
go chase down goals and learn and
improve but all three of us have two
sisters want to go do different crazy
things
um
and so with my son people ask me what
you expecting to be an entrepreneur i
was like no right what does he want to
do right now he's doing
his you know he's uh turning 13 in a
couple weeks
and he's looking at the date uh turning
13 so i'm going to have a teenager soon
and he's in his his big things are
acting in minecraft
and
we had some entrepreneur stuff like we
had him do
uh lemonade stand and uh went to my
daint studio and he was selling lemonade
outside there and maybe maybe
entrepreneurship comes back in some way
um
for making videos sometimes he wants to
be part of it sometimes he doesn't so
you know like you basically make it what
are you interested in because when you
when you care about something you're
much more likely to learn and so he
loves
he loves acting and he loves minecraft
so on our on our last school break i
took him to california and we went to
hollywood
and we you know i don't care about
hollywood but we we went to hollywood to
show him the hollow walk of fame and to
take him through the highlight was the
universal studios kind of behind the
scenes studio tour
because at least right now that's what
he's into
you know he's 13.
don't have to have him know what he
wants how do you introduce
new things to him right because we see a
lot of young people who are saying you
know i don't want to do that because i
don't like it yet they've never
actually
tried it right so
how do you feel that it's a good way to
introduce something new because you
wouldn't necessarily know about it or
not had their parent not or an adult not
introduced it to them i think kids are
being exposed to way more new things
than what we as parents
that's true
you know like just
from what they watch on youtube you know
they're exposed though i'm asking my son
and my nieces and nephews for like new
things to do right what new videos are
you watching what new music should i
listen to what new things are trending
i'm asking them for what's new as
opposed to me
teaching them what's new i think the key
thing is is listening being involved
in their lives and the things that they
care about as opposed to the things that
might want them to care about so
instead of
forcing my son to go
learn piano
or trumpet or something um he he really
cares about minecraft he got into it and
so i joined him on minecraft you know i
suck at minecraft
i i don't i didn't know the first time i
played minecraft i dug myself into a
hole and couldn't figure out how to do
that like this game is stupid
but but i i learned and i got better and
i improved and and there's a lot of
creativity in minecraft that if i didn't
know what it was it's easy to judge it
as just a waste of time or another video
game or something and
so because he's interested in it we
spend time like it's hard you know kids
don't want to just sit down and talk
about their life i guess at least when
you're 13 years old 12 years old right
maybe when they're older we'll see but
they don't want to just sit down and and
when you ask them hey how was your day
fine yeah you do
nothing and so how do you have
conversations and how do you how do you
lead them and how do you guide them and
mentor them i think it's through shared
activities shared experiences so
if you want to show bouncing back after
failure you know if i'm
if i'm playing minecraft and i got my
full netherright gear which is hard to
get and then i die and i lose all of it
right and i'm starting over then what
happens do i rage quit do i yell at my
computer do i blame the creeper that
blew me out right or is it okay that sex
yeah
deep breath we're starting over right
and like it that is demonstrating the
life lesson i think you could teach life
lessons through anything and if they
actually care about that thing then now
i'm demonstrating how
to be
an adult i guess uh as opposed to having
to be through
the things that i learned through so i
don't have to teach through
entrepreneurship but through books or
through piano and teach you through the
things that they actually care about um
we're looking at uh
uh
trying to do one of one of the things
that i loved about my mom is every
year she took one of the three of us to
something
that we cared about
and so when she took me it was to done
eating florida to go to spring training
toronto blue jays
uh because you get to you get to meet
the players in the parking lot and see
them you know i love baseball and she
kind of cared about baseball but it
wasn't really her thing was my thing
so we're looking at how do we do that
for
um for my son but also for my nieces and
nephews they they lost their mom a year
and a half ago and uh you know my wife
has kind of become
the pseudo mom and so they're
a lot more than just
nieces and nephews now um and so we're
looking at what's one thing that that i
could take them to every year and
just be about them
so my niece just turned 16 and she loves
anime i know nothing about anime like i
zero about anime but but i'm researching
like one of the anime conferences and
conventions coming up that
there's one coming up in la and i'm
going to talk to you this weekend and
maybe that becomes a thing that i take
her to let's go spend three days in la
at the anime conference
and uh and i'll get into it you know
maybe i'm dressing up maybe i'm standing
in line waiting to do a selfie with like
whoever
famous person is and and it's not about
me it's about the experience with her
and on that you know trying to sit down
and talk to her about life is is
challenging but when you experience a
trip together
and we're spending three days it's just
just me and her for three days doing
something she cares about there'll be
lots of opportunities for connection um
and understanding and listening and life
lessons inside of that for sure
for sure so yeah
like i actually caring and being
interested in the things that they're
interested in as opposed to the things
that you so true i love that so
you you at leia mentioned before you had
said that you you were slow you know you
found it difficult a little bit school
you went to three different schools
um you had trouble making friends from
time to time and you weren't getting the
extra attention that you needed
a lot of times um there's a lot of young
people today that feel that way
and so
a lot of teachers and i have been one
that included had said you know well
you know they just have difficulty
learning however we know from you
jim quick many other people young kids
it was just the way that they were
learning that was difficult
for them
what do you think is a good way for
teachers education instruction to happen
today
that what you think would have made a
difference if it was a little bit
different when you were in school well
one i had a undiagnosed hearing problem
and it led me to like i would sit under
my desk and clap during school
like the teacher would be teaching
something and i
you know i don't i don't remember this
anymore but like this is what my parents
i would sit under the desk at school
instead of sitting in my chair i would
sit under the desk at school and and not
pay attention and they thought i was
like ignoring them or a bad student and
really like i just couldn't hear
anything and so instead of sitting there
feeling dumb i tried to do something on
my own um i think that is a challenge in
that
teachers have so many kids in a
classroom and to spend individual time
with everybody becomes you know
challenging but it's you know on the
parents too then
internet didn't exist when that was me
right now
however old now now you can
um so maybe they have actually something
physically wrong or emotionally wrong or
something going on at home that it's not
actually a learning problem it's just
right
they're stressed out or they have a
physical problem that you know needs to
be solved um
the second would be and i mean again
just for that it's like creating a safe
space and taking the time to actually
care like i tell the story of madame
farr who is my teacher
mentor
my last year of high school and i went
from being a b and c student to a
straight 90s student after
meeting her once a week
i was the same person you know it's just
like that extra support and and belief
and having somebody to help me was great
um and then second is just understanding
how you learn so
i'm auditory is the worst way for me
uh
i i like to learn by seeing something
and i like to learn with having somebody
kind of guide me
and so my whole
history of feeling like a dummy and
stupid and can't learn was really oh i
just
can't learn that way
i need to have i need to have a guide
and when i have a guide and i can
actually see it right i'm actually a
great learner
but i didn't understand that until i was
like in my 20s so you know that's uh if
we can learn that earlier uh i think
it'd be a great gift that we can give i
agree with you
in that sense i think that that's one of
the biggest
um issues today with education and you
know yes there's a lot of different kids
in the in the class but you know it's
still
the system itself is still that one
track system
um that only works for one-third of kids
and so
um
so yeah it's interesting to hear that
because it's really just an alteration
of how the materials presented or how
you learn that would have made such a
big difference now going to piggyback on
your you were assigned madame farr miss
miss far madame
and she was your mentor in grade 12
right
and she made you believe in yourself you
were just like oh my gosh like
you said you had got straight a's and
and you it made all the difference
why do you think like what do you not
why what do you think would have
happened
had
you been assigned a mentor
in grade nine
yeah it would have made all the
difference in the world and and um i
i think what i i moved between madame
foreign miss as far because her we
actually i called her madame apart but
most people don't understand what was
she a french teacher she tried to say
mrs far sometimes but
yeah she was my french teacher uh
and
i went to a french immersion school
there was the third school that i went
the second school that i went to before
we transferred into my my other my final
school for high school and uh
i was just way ahead in french because i
went to french immersion and now i went
to regular school french was easy so i
was in class with people who were like
three years my age in and roasting them
on
on all the tests and exams and it was
super easy not because i was smart but
just because i was in such an intensive
program that this was easy stuff that
they were learning so i built a little
bit of a bond with her because she was
my teacher there and i think she felt
bad for me being
kind of picked on
because i'm with people who are two
three years older than me and i'm
destroying them but i'm the only one in
the class who's that young and had no
friends and so she took a liking to me i
guess and i'm grateful that my school
had that program
uh they paired the graduating students
with
a teacher
and the idea was that you would meet
once a week it was a teacher mentorship
program almost yeah you said that like
that's crazy um
i mean i think it's a combination of
like the students maybe didn't want to
meet the teachers and the teachers
weren't weren't pushing it because they
probably had a million other things to
do coaching classes you know clubs and
marketing and all that um
maybe i was too you know he's like okay
this
this
is what we do
i didn't ask enough questions or judge
it it's like okay well i guess i'm
meeting i'm meeting her and i got
assigned her which is great because
maybe she picked me i don't even know
i was probably actually if i think back
of like students picking kids she would
probably have picked me um it's not some
random assignment but um
yeah and i mean i had already graduate i
had already finished all the highest
level french classes by that point i
wasn't even taking french anymore uh
because i already finished grade 12
french like in grade 10.
so she wasn't helping me with school she
wasn't helping me with the content of
the material you know meeting her every
week i meet her once a week in the
morning before class started
and she would just ask me
about how things was going and
um
it just felt great and i had my parents
who always inject me with belief too but
for whatever reason like being in the
environment having having a teacher who
kind of knew what i was going through
really helped so if i had that a great
nine yeah i mean
what what a difference it would have
made i don't know how we
you know obviously the more customized
you can make it and the more belief you
can inject in the students the better
results are going to get i don't have
the answer for how do you do that at
scale well it's interesting
because because like statistics show
that
75
of students of students who are mentored
actually go on to graduate college or
university um i don't you don't exactly
quote me on that right now because i
don't remember i would i was researching
this last summer and like we there's so
much
importance on mentoring and mentoring
programs
yet there are
there are not a lot in
most
schools
um or they wait until it's they make it
optional or they wait until it's you
know high school or 12th grade let's get
you know in the mentoring part of that
so um i just i feel that
mentoring
is such an important part of
of helping young people and youth today
but there's very limited to
to that
uh that that exists right now so
um
if
you could
you know
as you were not making friends if
there's a young person today who's doing
the same thing with you right now like
feeling the same didn't have a lot
doesn't have a lot of friends or feeling
left out or struggling in school
what
what what do you say to them it's almost
like let's be like talking to your
younger self right so what would you say
to them what i would say to them would
be more just listening like i think just
being here
you know more than anything else more
than yeah like they need a friend
so
just be their friend ask them hey what
do you want to do today
play minecraft cool i wouldn't judge
them and say go do this like let's okay
let's let's go play minecraft together
let's go
to the anime conference together or
whatever you know do something to just
listen and be with them
is going to go a lot further than
telling them well you should do
x
um
what i would be looking for then is that
how to how can they find community
through the thing that they love
so
how do they
if it's a minecraft club if it's a
volleyball club you know we're looking
at getting some of our you know it's a
great example my nephew
uh wants to join volleyball
you know he was he was on youtube
watching volleyball
tournaments and stuff he's now obsessed
with the volleyball like how did that
happen i didn't tell him volleyball
nobody told him volleyball he just found
the video on volleyball now he could so
now we're looking at how do we get into
a volleyball program like what's the
closest volleyball when does the season
start how do we get him in
how do we practice am i going to now be
serving
playing i mean yeah exactly like
i used to play volleyball just in like
gym class but i'm not a volleyball
expert but all of a sudden now we're you
know maybe we get into volleyball and
maybe he maybe in three months he
doesn't care about anymore and now he
cares about divington or he cares about
something completely different cool like
i think that's that's part of the
experience
um and so doing it with them but then
encouraging them to be a part of
something that they can and everything
that is done solo can be done in groups
like volleyball requires it is a team
sport but um minecraft you can join
servers you can play with friends one of
the things that really helped
him was was
um
doing minecraft and valor and being on
like you went from being really shy and
introverted to then doing voice comms
where you're you're on a call with the
people who are on your team
and
building friendships and learning how to
communicate and learning how to talk to
people through the thing that he cares
about instead of forcing him into right
bane class
actually my minecraft and and fortnite
and all that because you could talk on
there with them you know it was great
for my like english language learners
because they would have to speak in
english because most of them that are
there on there and want to play with
speak english so they had to they it was
it was great i was like how'd you where
are you practicing they're like yeah
minecraft
fortnight i'm like oh good for you like
it was great
well i
yeah because it's the thing they care
about like tim ferriss who wrote the far
work week had a great example we were
talking about when he's trying to learn
a new language
he really loves martial arts and
wrestling and
physical contact kind of sports and so
he'll
join those groups and pick up those
books around
that style so he's trying to learn
chinese he'll learn whatever the martial
art is in china and try to pick that up
and it'll force him to learn the
language because he cares about the
thing as opposed to picking up
just a textbook on the words so
absolutely yeah i think it's fantastic
like you're trying to learn english and
you care about minecraft it's actually
fun and you want to learn how you know
how do you how do you say
right shut down that tree in english now
now you're look you're actually curious
about it and you research it and you
learn it so you can apply it into your
life um and that's where i think we get
a lot of things wrong is we we tend to
judge
uh the actions
if you look at parents and it's out of
love for the most part right it's just
we they want you to succeed
but um a lot of it i think in a in a
2022 environment is misguided because
the opportunities available to somebody
who's
even me i'm 42. the opportunities
available to me at 42 compared to my
parents at 42 it's just a completely
different world like you can make more
money playing minecraft now and making
videos and winning tournaments than you
can be so true so true on that one um
last question
okay and so i really want you to if you
had to paint a picture in your mind
what does the ideal school or education
look like
i've struggled with this one i don't
have an answer i haven't spent a huge
amount of time like really think tanking
it so i would almost flip the question
like i'm curious what you think and
maybe you can add that at the end um
i think i think mentorship definitely
plays a bigger role i don't know how to
scale it i don't know if it requires
having more
people coming in more more parent
volunteers more
i think less just
here's what you have to learn like most
of the stuff we learn is forgotten
most of the stuff that you pick up is
really just memorization to pass the
test and so it's not really training us
to learn things that that matter and i
think most i i struggle with this with
with my son and my nieces and nephews
was like this is this is useless
right like i'm never going to use this
right why am i studying this yeah you're
right
i got nothing it is useless i don't use
any of this am i like the chance of you
actually buying this is pretty much zero
but
it's good building the discipline and
the structure
absolutely go do it
but it's not as strong not as strong a
message um but
yeah definitely trying to figure out
ways to teach teach kids how to learn i
think it's the most important than
teaching them what to learn like how to
learn versus what to learn is is huge um
people can learn bill gates had this
great quote
which i've been playing with um and i'm
going to kind of mess it up word for
word but the idea was you can learn a
lot more when you're in community than
trying to do it on your own so even if
college or university or the school
system is not
uh
structured very well
the fact that you're doing it together
really increases your ability to follow
through
really drives up your your likelihood of
following through
which if i look at movement makers
it's what i'm trying to do is that
there's no set curriculum what do you
guys want
what do you want me to talk about like
what's the theme for this
this session because i want to make
content and have discussions on what you
guys care about the most and it's never
a cust it's never a photocopy of what
was two weeks ago or a month ago or two
months ago it's always like the latest
of what i'm working on but then the
collaboration and connection between
you guys as well i think is yeah i think
is important um i i don't know that we
even need like just thinking out loud
now brainstorming while you're here like
the fact that we even put people in
groups based only oh absolutely it's
probably ridiculous absolutely because
you have different levels right your
kids are at different levels they could
be at one level math or different level
and it's something else and so
you know
okay you're in
11th grade or 10th grade simply because
you're
you know this age like it's almost it's
almost absurd so
um
[Music]
yeah and different interests
like people care about i honestly i
think
i think
if you look at the club system and the
different schools that have different
clubs
you
if you look at life skills and actual
value kids probably i'm going out on a
uh on a limb on this one but i would i
would guess the kids get more value out
of the clubs than they do out of the
actual classes so if i go to a chess
club
and everybody there cares a lot about
chess
and it's all sorts of ages because it's
the entire school but it's only the
80 people who care about chess
and i'm learning and i'm making
connections and friendships and
strategies and i'm
i'm competing but also playing but some
of the people who are
um at similar levels to me even if there
are different age groups i think
i think that's probably the highest
value so how do you replicate that out
and how you create curriculum
curriculum how do you create you know i
don't know what alternative schools are
doing but um i mean how do you have
mentors come in who actually are living
their life you know like most guidance
counselors
don't like their own life and so they're
now
giving guidance to other kids and how
they should live their life
um so i do a lot more community i do a
lot more involvement i do a lot more
asking people to come in and speak i do
a lot more customization i do a lot more
mixing
of of interests and age groups
um
a lot more action as opposed to studying
let's go out and build something make
something don't even in my even my
fourth year university course
on entrepreneurship it was just about
writing the business plan and i was
already running my business at the time
like go go and create a company
go do something go go instead of just
studying in a textbook right
but all of that requires
a completely different way of thinking
about education um but but i don't know
how you do that at scale
without it costing a thousand times more
i'm sure there are ways i'm figuring out
the scale part that's why people like
you
everything else that you said like for
my online school that i that i have like
it's that's exactly what it is like you
know kids aren't mixed in with each
other because why does it have to
to be just one level grade level or
another level you know if i'm having all
the kids you know read
uh build to serve then why do they have
to be in a different classroom to
rebuild the serve and to
you know then have that discussion
around it and work together to do a
project around it right and so when you
when you think about it it's about
you know
taking those doing a podcast about like
you know or having like one of my one of
my students she um
had to interview the guy that shot
archduke francis ferdinand and she loves
to do animation so she was able to do an
animation cartoon of her because she
doesn't like to be on she herself
doesn't like to be on camera an
animation of her introducing him but she
had to research the theory and why he
did it and all that stuff so her
questions had to be based on that and
his answers had to be based on it but
she was able to do it in the form of a
cartoon which was pretty cool
that was high school she was in 10th
grade no let's see yeah she was in 10th
grade when she did that
so pretty cool
i think that's a killer age i i think
that's a great i think you know what to
add on to that then i would
i think you need strong
ties into the community to then give
people
internship programs
yeah around the things that they care
about because if you if you take this
girl and she cares about animation and
then she goes and does like we're gonna
say
here's what i would love to say is like
hey
ignore french
ignore music class
ignore calculus
ignore history unless it's like she
loves history and archduke ferdinand
like ignore all the stuff that you don't
care about but this is basically what my
parents did for me it's like ignore all
the stuff you don't care about but you
have to you have to spend time on
something that you do care about and
it's that push to go and study and learn
and be great at the thing that you do
care about and so if it's animation for
her
then
she's gonna graduate high school
being kick ass at animation
in like zero at everything else
which
how do we set her up to have success in
life which would be let's get her some
kind of opportunity either to start her
own business and animation or intern at
an animation company who when they hire
her will not care about her french
mark or her trumpet mark or like all
they care about is can she do the job
and so if you're gonna go that um
extreme in the curriculum or like lack
of curriculum customized curriculum then
then what's the next time so that
they're not left
we're given in the next step so that
they're not they don't feel screwed that
well that was a fun four years but now i
can't even get into the university of my
choice
well the idea is to get them while
they're in high school that internship
and so that then for especially with the
the low-income people so that they don't
have to my everybody can go to college
or university or afford it so then they
can get jobs right out of high school
because they have a specialization in a
certain area
yeah honestly it might even be it might
even make sense to go
to go category by category you know it's
like if you look at how how did facebook
blow up well they were only for
um university campuses at the beginning
and it's how a lot of companies blow up
is they start with one thing and then
they get great at that and then they
expand expand expand expand expand so
how do you build
the animation school
or the
you know acting school or the
entrepreneur school or the writing
school or the something and you focus on
getting great at that and in helping
people build projects around those
interests and then getting them
opportunities so that they're making
money in and they're set up for their
career
and then add another layer and another
layer right as opposed to like trying to
do everything all at once
yeah it's probably how i would approach
it it's great well
yeah like i would do i would do
entrepreneurship for sure you know just
how do you so what's an entrepreneurship
school look like well we're gonna start
businesses together
and then i'd be
having a i would have a board of a board
of advisors for the school
and the job for there is to try to get
the kids who are making
deals
you know and go go get them so that they
can actually build their business when
they come i'm so excited that you said
that because
you're part of my
mastermind the entrepreneur mastermind
that i started for this coming school
year you're one of the weeks
and i use your stuff all the time i can
make curriculum out of your stuff
forever because that's what that's just
so much
for these young kids to do so i'm
working on it little by little secondary
students so you're going to be known
very well in uganda as well this coming
year we have 50 kids in uganda that
we're
sponsoring so it's exciting
i love it it's a huge problem it's not
one that i've spent a
crazy amount of time thinking on because
i'm focused more on kind of the
entrepreneurs out there but um
i love it i love being a part of it i
love that you're taking it on it's it's
one of the you know top 10 problems in
the world and if you fix that
you're going to fix a whole lot of a lot
of other things well we went way over
and i'm very excited that we did so i'm
just super grateful to you and
very blessed to have you in my life
thank you evan
christie right you in the house
appreciate you christy thank you
everybody for watching and we'll see you
soon if you want to see me coach another
entrepreneur check out the video right
there next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there if i wanted to sell coaching this
would be a great example the ultimate
goal is impact right it's like how do i
reach more people and if you can turn it
into a business and you can reach more
people i love that okay i'm gonna do i'm
gonna do 50 reach outs today